2021 has been jam-packed with finding
new things in breath of the wild despite
it being almost five years since it
launched and every year there are
hundreds of glitches discovered that
you've never heard of so i'll cover a
variety of minor and major finds this
year that you might not have seen before
if you enjoy breath of the wild content
let us know with a like now let's go
back to the beginning of the year
early in january of 2021 glitch hunters
such as kinok and yuda were still hot on
the heels of a major glitch found in
late 2020 called memory storage a glitch
that allowed players to start a brand
new game with the bow of light and all
of their equipment basically a new game
plus but this glitch led to a number of
other discoveries that paved the way to
break the game even more one of which
was called inventory corruption by the
middle of january players were finding
out that by performing the memory
storage glitch then gaining some extra
slots through hesto durability values
would carry over strangely to the new
file such as with shield durability into
arrow counts a nice way to start a new
file with a massive quiver
yiga sword stealing while its popularity
exploded later in june 2021 this glitch
was actually discovered quietly by bot w
in january this trick proves that the
yiga blade masters in the yiga hideout
have the capability of confiscating
pretty much any weapon including the
legendary master sword by clipping into
the yiga hideout then kiting the blade
master all the way to the korok forest
you can cause them to yank the powerful
sword right out of the pedestal
a strange glitch called super hold
smuggling is discovered by let me think
of a username by using a multitude of
glitches to warp link's coordinates then
smuggling an item at the exact same time
link then goes into a strange state of
permanently holding an item in the menu
this state led to another discovery by
axk who found that this could be
combined with an old camera glitch to
play breath of the wild in first person
a brand new way to play the game
a nifty trick user snsk2s found called
golden gauntlets arrives on the scene by
tricking the game to pick up heavy items
with the bomb pickup animation instead
you can pick up and carry previously
heavy objects with ease and throw them
even farther this glitch was named after
a famous piece of equipment in ocarina
of time where golden gauntlets allowed
link to lift extremely heavy things with
no effort
another trick snsk2s found was unarmed
link which causes the game to think you
have a weapon equipped in your hand but
actually is instead put away and
sheathed on your back at the same time
this is caused by entering the tie flow
ruins border at the exact same time you
pick up a bomb which interrupts your
shooting animation but the game still
thinks they have the weapon equipped
mostly a useless glitch but can lead to
some comedic chase scenes
the summer months of june and july for
breath of the wild were packed with
discoveries one of which was bomb hole
displacement satogashi found out that by
scoping then summoning a bomb quickly
next to an object makes the bomb spawn
inside of the object pushing either link
or the object quickly away from each
other this could be used to push and
launch items or push link to gain bullet
time
in breath of the wild there are hundreds
of hidden treasure chests but there are
also a handful of them that weren't
properly placed during development and
were impossible to get many of them have
been reached over the years through
advances in glitches but the final one
at heiress beach seemed impossible until
a user cleric used a multitude of
techniques ranging from quality clipping
moon jumping rune recharging and a ton
of patience to push the final treasure
chest into his hands
[Music]
octo balloon duplication was found by
satogashi by taking advantage of the
octo balloons attachment mechanic
dropping weapons on them at specific
times made the weapon be able to be
picked up two times in a row making it
one of the more efficient ways to
duplicate weapons
[Music]
this led to many other implications as
shortly after in july active arrow
smuggling was found again by satogashi a
side effect of the previously found
glitch doing the same trick but drawing
an arrow makes the bow clip through the
floor and after waiting for a while will
cause the animation to start looping
aggressively causing some insanely cool
visual glitches
master source stealing became a reality
on the ripe day of july 4th 2021 by a
bot w the most simple trick had most
glitch hunters scratching their heads to
why this wasn't found earlier using a
campfire next to the master sword then
looking up causes a master sword to be
slightly unloaded and can be picked up
this campfire loading trick was then
used for fun in other scenarios such as
being able to save in situations
normally impossible and making enemies
have permanent ice or fire properties
jelly bouncing was another technique
found this year showing yet again the
usefulness of chuchu jellies user aozaki
1971 found that unlike elemental jellies
normal choo choo jelly specifically have
a small quirk of having a small physical
splash to push things around so by dash
attacking to break it and be on top of
it link would then be launched into the
air high enough to perform bullet time
and can be used for wind bombs or combat
bow lift smuggling slide also known as
blss was found in september of 2021
first snsk 2's finds the bow lift
smuggle which causes link to pick up an
object and a bow at the same time but
legend of link then found that holding b
and clambering over a curb would cause
link to hover and freely move about the
world this was one of the biggest
discoveries of this year and has had
huge implications for both speed runs
and casual play to let you move around
the world using no stamina or health
continuing his glitch hunting rampage
snsk 2s puts material smuggling on the
map by using a scope or a camera holding
an item then immediately holding another
item the material is then left floating
in place as an object that's liftable
this could be lyft smuggled as well just
adding to the already vast list of
smuggling types that have been found in
breath of the wild
[Music]
the initial first person glitch was a
painstaking process that took quite a
bit of work and equipment to acquire but
that process was again made easier by
snsk2s by a new discovery of the updated
new first person glitch not requiring
the difficult super hold smuggling
process found earlier this year by
weapon smuggling first then a
combination of switching equipment and
holding items then pausing and engaging
the camera at the same time first person
breath of the wild was possible anywhere
[Music]
at this point in november link has had
enough of these insane glitches wanted
to reject humanity and just return to
monkey user hanabi link finds out by
using rivali's gale then simply
unequipping a weapon and cancelling the
gale link would keep his crouched
animation from his waist up ah truly a
return to form
[Music]
finally no hozarashi discovers a way to
remove link's shika slate while still
being able to use it for rune abilities
this was found after performing an old
glitch called apparatus storage but with
the added step of loading another file
during bullet time instead now link's
mind powers were enough to use rune
abilities no need for the chica slate
while there were many other discoveries
found this year what's important to note
is that things will continue to be found
every year and in the years to come with
breath of the wild 2 fast approaching in
2022 players will be ready to find what
can be uncovered in the highly
anticipated sequel if you enjoyed this
video let us know with a like and
subscribe to gamespot to keep up with
the latest breath of the wild content
[Music]
you